Thor: Ragnarok is a huge hit with critics
and audiences and sends its titular hero off
on a bold new adventure that boasts long-time
ramifications for him, his friends, and for
Asgard.
It also sets up a new three-film trilogy arc
for the Hulk, who plays a major role alongside
our title hero.
Naturally, it leaves some plot threads dangling,
with lingering questions that range from Loki's
allegiance to how Ragnarok will affect the
upcoming Avengers: Infinity War.
Many of these stories will be picked up in
future Marvel films, but some are a bit more
nebulous and may not be answered for quite
some time—if ever.
Let's take a look at some of the biggest questions
left unanswered by Thor: Ragnarok.
It should go without saying, but brace for
spoilers ahead!
Is Hulk here to stay?
We find out in Ragnarok's second act that
Bruce Banner has been in his Hulk form for
two whole years, and he later describes this
particular transformation as different from
any other.
Apparently, his consciousness has been absent
all the while, with only Hulk and no Banner
knocking around in his mind.
"Hulk like fire."
He's afraid that if he transforms again, he
may never be able to revert back to Banner.
But that doesn't stop him from transforming
into Hulk again when when Thor's ragtag Revengers
find themselves in desperate need against
Hela's forces and the giant demon Surtur.
Now we're left to wonder whether we'll see
Bruce Banner as we know him again.
Where's Sif?
Sif really dodged a bullet in Thor: Ragnarok's
first act by not being available to charge
against Hela with her cohorts.
That being said, we've gotta wonder where
she's at during this movie.
Sif gets nary a mention throughout the entirety
of Ragnarok, which is strange considering
her prominence in the prior two films in the
series.
"WHAT."
Admittedly we know her absence is due to actress
Jaimie Alexander filming her TV show Blindspot,
but that doesn't quite explain the decision
not to mention her at all.
You'd think a throwaway line explaining she
was off-world might have been warranted, considering
she had a couple significant appearances in
Marvel's Agents of Shield television series.
Has Loki turned good for good?
Has the God of Mischief permanently turned
over a new leaf?
That might depend on whether he took the Tesseract,
and leaked footage from D23 seems to indicate
that he did.
But at the end of Ragnarok, we see him at
a tepid peace with his brother and the people
of Asgard.
He fights valiantly in the battle of Ragnarok
and shares a quiet, friendly moment with Thor
in its aftermath, seeming to confirm that
he wants their relationship to heal.
He even seems to support Thor taking his rightful
place on the throne as king of Asgard.
But as Marvel fans know all too well, nothing
with Loki is as it seems.
Even if his aiding Thor's cause in Ragnarok
comes from a sincere place, there's a very
good chance that it also serves as a stepping
stone on Loki's path to retaking the throne
and doing away with his brother.
Where will New Asgard be?
As Thor: Ragnarok comes to an end, the realm
of Asgard is destroyed by Surtur.
Asgard was the first true foray into the cosmic
side of the Marvel universe and has served
a crucial role in the movies' world-building
over the last few years—and just like that,
it's gone.
Fortunately, Thor and the Revengers successfully
evacuate the realm's citizens, so the casualty
count is low, but the film still ends with
an entire population adrift in space.
Something similar happened in the comics that
landed Thor and all of Asgard in the middle
of Oklahoma.
So, who knows?
Maybe this is just an easy way to let Thor
rule his kingdom a little closer to the Avengers
action for Infinity War?
We just know that all of those Asgardians
have to go somewhere, and their newly-crowned
King Thor needs a kingdom.
Whose ship is that?
In the first of two post-credits sequences,
the Asgardian refugee ship is shown being
confronted by a massive spaceship of unknown
origin.
We're never shown who's piloting it, but Marvel's
Kevin Feige has dubbed the vessel the Sanctuary
II, which means it's most likely the flagship
of Thanos, who's edging ever nearer to our
heroes as the impending Infinity War is getting
closer.
Is Surtur dead?
Surtur, a hellish monster prophesied to bring
about the titular end of days, makes his debut
in Thor: Ragnarok—and, sure enough, he does
just that.
The film ends with his ultimate destruction
of Asgard, and with it, his apparent death.
We can only assume he perished along with
the realm—along with Hela, the Goddess of
Death, but we don't actually see anyone die.
We only see them disappear.
As Ragnarok is an event that functions cyclically,
having happened before and almost definitely
happening again someday, who can say for sure
that Surtur is dead?
Perhaps he's simply gone back to his realm
to start the cycle over again.
Will Thor get Mjolnir back?
One of the more shocking moments in Thor:
Ragnarok comes in its first act, when Hela
crushes Thor's hammer, Mjolnir, with her bare
hand.
It's a huge moment, as Mjolnir is thought
to be indestructible; perhaps even more surprising
is the fact that he doesn't get Mjolnir back
by the time the film is over.
Admittedly, part of the character's arc is
coming into his own as the rightful king of
Asgard and the God of Thunder—, Mjolnir
only helps him channel his powers.
It isn't their source.
Still, a Thor without a hammer seems somewhat
naked, and we can't help but wonder if he'll
be getting his favorite toy back.
"Every time I threw it it would always come
back to me."
Mjolnir looked pretty busted after Hela had
her way with it, but when dealing with Norse
mythology and comic book characters, practicality
isn't really a priority.
Don't be surprised if these two find a way
back together.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!